in this video we're going to talk a
little bit about
ionic compounds and specifically
we're going to think about the empirical
formulas for ionic compounds
so the first thing you might be
wondering is well refreshed me sal and
what ionic compound is
well we're going to be dealing with ions
which you can view as the charged
versions
of atoms so if you start with a neutral
atom the only way it gets charged is if
you are gaining or
losing electrons and that would make it
an ion and a compound
that tells us that we're dealing with
more than one type of
element so let's just get a little bit
of a refresher here
so we talk about this in depth in other
videos but we know that atoms
like to have a full outer shell of
electrons a full number of
valence electrons now in most
situations that means having eight
valence electrons
and that's why these noble gases right
over here are considered to be so stable
they're already very satisfied they have
eight
valence electrons they all have
different numbers of electrons but that
outer shell
is eight and the one exception is when
we're talking about that first shell and
once again this is all review that we
talk about in other videos
that first shell is most stable when it
has two electrons and that's why helium
is
also so stable so in general when
atoms react they tend to react in a way
that gets them
to either two electrons in their first
shell or eight electrons in any other
outer shell whichever one is their
outermost shell
now how they get that they can do that
in several different ways and it really
depends on whether we're talking about
metals or non-metals
so first let me separate the non-metals
here so hydrogen is a non-metal
and then we'll come here and this little
staircase looking thing
so everything to the right and up of
this dividing line that i just drew
these are all non-metals including
hydrogen now when non-metals interact to
try to get to that full
outer shell they tend to do it by
sharing electrons with each other
for example two hydrogens each of which
have one
outer electron well they can form a
covalent bond which we talk about in
other videos
and then they're each sharing each
other's electrons so they can kind of
pretend
like they have a full outer shell now
it's different when we're talking about
a non-metal
interacting with a metal which we can
generally refer to the rest of the
periodic table there's other further
subclassifications
when you have a metal interacting with a
non-metal
what typically happens is that the
non-metal is actually going to
gain electrons to get to a full outer
shell
while the metal will lose electrons to
get to a full outer shell
so i'll give you an example and i use
this example a lot and this is a common
example that gets us to table salt
if you look at sodium right over here a
neutral sodium atom
has one valence electron one electron in
that third
shell well the easiest way for it to get
to a full outer shell is to give up that
one electron
and then it will have the same number of
electrons as neon
it still has 11 protons which make it a
sodium it'll have the same number of
electrons as
neon and then it will be happy so sodium
tends to form a sodium ion
with a positive one charge
now we can go on the other side of the
periodic table if we were to look at
chlorine right over here
chlorine has seven valence electrons it
has seven electrons in that third
shell well the easiest way for it to get
a full eight
is to nab an electron from some places
to gain an electron
so chlorine tends to take electrons from
other atoms and forms a negative
charge and becomes the chloride anion
now what do you think will happen if you
put a bunch of sodium and a bunch of
chlorine
together well the chlorine is probably
going to take electrons from the sodium
or the sodium is likely to give
electrons to the chlorine
and then you have these two ions one is
positively charged one is negatively
charged
they will be attracted to each other and
that's what forms the ionic compound
sodium chloride and this is the
empirical formula for table salt for
sodium chloride for every sodium
ion you have a chloride ion it's
interesting to note that even though the
sodium has a positive charge
the chlorine which is now the chloride
anion has a negative charge
that the ionic compound in total
has a neutral charge which is an
interesting property of
these ionic compounds